thinking completely out of the box
thinking outside the box
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to make
a difference in this world now I see a
lot of top tens we make a lot of videos
every week for you some of the rules
come up over and over and over and over
again so the goal of the one rule series
is to combine all of those similar rules
into one video so today we're going to
learn how you can think outside the box
enjoy
[Music]
when you're wanting to do something out
of the box there's always going to be
opposition from a society where parents
want you to subscribe to a certain
things a settled job settled life in
terms of family and your thinking
completely out of the box as soon as you
want to do something out of the box
you're going to have to face challenges
from the family side after a while
however when my family saw where I was
reaching how I was impacting people's
lives however how I was really able to
make a difference in the world they
accepted it very well and I feel in
terms of coping up with the challenges
of how my friends have moved on the
industry I think it's a question of
self-discovery I hate I hate being a
part of a mold that the world created
for me I don't want to subscribe to the
mold that the world creates for you I
don't want to live a life in a paradigm
that the world is created for me I want
to discover my own mold I want to have a
paradigm that I have invented you know
only when you discover yourself only
when you live a life for what you are
created is when you feel happy satisfied
not just happy and satisfied you're
super effective even in the corporate
world today
loads of people are just living in life
which they are not created for because
it pays the bucks and why do they need
the box to pay the taxes to pay the
pills bills to pay the market is but
they're not living a life of what they
are created for so it's basically kind
of you know fitting in just because it
pays you but I decided I didn't want to
fit in so when I saw others moving on my
friends my colleagues going on high up I
really did not feel insecure at all
because I didn't want to fit in to be
someone else I wanted to find myself
discover myself there's as soon as you
of successful in your self-discovery man
you are effective and completely
satisfied every gym I went here was
always they had a set way every gym had
a set way of doing things don't do it
this way do it that way
so that was just a normal thing that I
thought I thought just people just have
their own set way and you must do it
that way you must stand this way you
must kick this way you must punch this
way but with John when I went to John I
met Michael John cabinet a straight
blast Jim I wasn't like that he had a
more open mind and he encouraged
different movements and I'd never
experienced that before I've never heard
a coach say that to me before
and that's took my head and I thought to
myself you know this guy is thinking
outside the box you know I mean that he
has a vision that everything works and
he encourages every movement because
ultimately there is a time and a place
for every single move so I just ha
I just knew one when I met John and I
when he spoke it made complete sense to
me and that was he I stuck with him and
he stuck with me and the rest is history
what I'm trying to get people to
understand is that our conventional
notions of disadvantage and advantage
aren't accurate that we've called lots
of things disadvantages when in fact
it's more complicated than that and so
the reason I started with that story and
also I retell the story of David and
Goliath start the book because if you
look at the story closely everything you
think was a disadvantage about David
actually isn't and Goliath is not what
he looks like he looks like this in da
middle giant in fact he probably had a
medical condition called acromegaly
which is Solly's this is sort of a size
thing you bring a medicine here in the
Bible do this because if you the middle
you start digging into these things you
discover these little pockets have been
arguing about these things for years for
50 years endocrinologists have been
arguing about whether Goliath had a
tumor on his pituitary gland and which
would explain his height because when
you have a tumor in your tutor gland it
over you or produces human growth
hormone and you can't really on Dre the
giant read this condition other than
foot for a be seven-foot for ya but one
of the side effects is that it can
constrict your optic nerves and leave
you largely with very very limited
eyesight so the the one of the
explanations for why Goliath behaved so
strangely and why he doesn't perceive
that David is not intending to fight off
David comes down the mountain
and he's got no sword and no armor he
clearly is not intending to fight a
sword fight and Goliath just sits there
like he's oblivious well the answer is
maybe he could only see this far right
so it changes everything and you realize
wait a minute the Giant is weighed down
by a hundred pounds of armor and can't
see anything
right he's like like this right so
anyway I do more with that story but
it's all about this trying to get people
to take a step back and understand that
we can give up because we have these
look or feel powerless because we have
these empty definitions or flawed
definitions of advantage six albums
original albums of Iran a throne record
various records were good music to talk
about man but seriously yeezus
Bravo dude I mean that is one of the
most creative records of you know of any
genre I've had in a very very long time
and you know just in terms of your
output your most exciting sounding
record I think man oh thank you very
much you know yeah I feel you know I was
able to start just making exactly what
was in my mind again I'm not having to
speak with the textures of the time
because you know cruel summer is
definitely kanye west and is something
kind of weird and off about mercy like
when it has the high pitch yeah that
type of sound it sounds like art still a
little bit even though it's obviously
was a radio smash but it's still when
when I you know get into the idea like
the trap drums and things like that are
certain you know songs that are blatant
you know radio hits it's like I'm
speaking with today's texture and that's
you know and you look if you look at it
200 years from now it's not gonna stand
out in the way that you know 808 or
Jesus stands out and completely can push
or redefine or make people say you know
hey I completely hate that or I
completely love that but let me just
think differently because everybody is
like bound to these you know no pun
intended
they're bound to 16 bars and eight bars
and you know the normal radio the radio
thing I was talking to Frank Ocean about
this and said like you know my mom got
arrested for the sit-ins and now we're
more like the sit-outs likes it off of
radio yeah and say hey radio
come to us yeah you know we need to find
something new because it's being you
know controlled in a way and and
manufactured in a way that in you know
really awesome you know artists you know
can make amazing music and and that
break as far past it's like something
that's very like formulaic so it almost
feels like a duty to you in a weird way
having the people here having people's
attention and for great music to be able
to say well if I'm not challenging them
if I'm not challenging myself not
challenging radio what am i doing yeah
well I'm not I'm not trying to
regurgitate myself I show I showed
people that I understand how to make
perfect you know dark fantasy could be
considered to be perfect you know I say
I know how to make perfect but that's
not what I'm here to do I'm here to
crack and crack the pavement and make
new grounds you know sonically and in
society culturally so don't let
expertise
silence you work to find new solutions
to old problems think outside the
parameters that restrict other people's
thoughts just because you're a novice on
the job just because you haven't faced
the same challenges just because you
haven't climbed the same cliffs doesn't
mean that you can't contribute to
solutions in very significant ways when
you're chided for your naivete and you
will be remind your critics that an
amateur built the art experts built the
Titanic think outside the parameters
that restrict other people's thinking I
really love that quote from Peyton and I
think for you to have success in any
field you are going to have to do it
your way if you want to be a singer you
can't do it like Madonna like Britney
like the Beatles like Elton John whoever
you can't be them you can only be
yourself and have the courage to model
success to find what has worked for
different people but then you need to
tweak it so that it fits for you there
is no one path for you as a creative
individual because you have never lived
before this is the first life that you
are living so there is no exact
blueprint you still have to figure it
out even if you're pulling things from
different people and that's a scary
part because the temptation is to go and
follow exactly what somebody else has
done follow the exact plan that they did
but that's not how you're gonna achieve
success because you will only be a clone
of somebody else instead of unleashing
your true art your true creativity to
create something that can be meaningful
and lasting and world-changing I think
it's especially hard because it's never
been done before and so instead of only
following somebody else's path you have
to go out and create your own I look at
my own YouTube channel and when I was in
the earlier days of my channel I made
this video that I was really proud of
that I really enjoyed and I said that
somebody was in the movie industry and
he hated it because the movie was six
minutes long and he said no video should
be six minutes long on YouTube and he
said the most popular YouTube videos are
30 seconds or a minute or whatever it
was and the fact that yours is 6 minutes
long means that it's gonna be a failure
and how sad would it have been for me to
listen this guy who who knows what he's
talking about who's who has the
experience in the industry who has all
the stats and data to back him up how
sad would have been for me to listen to
him and say no to shrink down to a
lesser version of myself was something
that I loved and was really passionate
about but not do it because this guy
who's an expert said I shouldn't do it
how many times do you listen to the
people around you who have no idea what
they're talking about or we didn't they
did they're in the industry they can't
give you the right direction that you
need for your life and that was the
birth of the little man that guy that
individual became little man for me as a
as you know a human embodiment of what
little man is and now he's become a
symbol for anybody who's hating on your
idea who tries to trash who tries to
bring you down that video spoke to me I
loved it and so I had the courage to put
it up even though the people around me
said not to and by the way that video
was the first video I had on my channel
to hit 1 million views and so you're
gonna have people around you who tell
you that it can't be done that it's not
smart they shouldn't do it and that
doesn't always mean that it's gonna work
out - I've tried a lot of stuff that
people said was stupid that that didn't
work out at all but just the fact that
somebody is telling you that doesn't
work
shouldn't be the the be-all and end-all
at the end of the day you need to listen
here you got to listen to your heart you
got to listen to what makes you come
alive and at least knowing if I did not
post that video I would live with regret
for the rest of my life that I didn't
post it or that I cut it down or that I
made it something that I wasn't truly
proud of or at least I would know to
have the certainty that it didn't work
out or the good fortune that it did work
out and so stop only listening to those
people around you take their advice for
what it is advice but at the end of the
day you have to make a decision on
what's best for your life then you got
one chance to live it so do a good job
assuming you're great at your craft that
you flex your muscles enough to to be
recognized as you have mastery of the
thing that at that point it becomes how
can you be different not just better and
whether that's the way you see the world
whether that's the project that you're
working on whether it's what your
aspirations like listening to talk about
Travis from uber he's a friend and he
came to me and he'd had some initial
success in San Francisco and he said I
wanna you know this service to Seattle
can you help me introduce some people
and I was like I didn't know what you're
working on like talk to me about it but
and the the capability the capacity for
thinking different and thinking big was
so clear with Travis that it's there's
sort of this desire to want to be a part
of that movement and in order to you
know you've probably heard this saying
also that it's hard to get weird going
if you don't know where you want to go
right if you just walk in the woods you
know are you if you don't have a
destination that's probably you know
you're not going to arrive at that
destination so it is a matter of how can
I you know and also the Apple slogan
think different like it really is about
different and standing out standing out
is one way thinking big is another way
that's why I collapse it all into how do
you be different not just better because
at the very top pro golfers or like
musicianship the the difference between
the best and the next best is like it
can't even measure it but whose
their own thing who has a vision that's
radically different and they see the
world tour lens that no one else sees
that is what people can notice and say
oh my gosh I had a vision of you know
one of the things I did was create the
first iPhone app that shared photos to
social networks it was called best
camera a year and a half before
Instagram and path and all that stuff it
was radical for me as a professional
photographer who had you know hundreds
of thousands of dollars in gear and
traveled all over the world for the
apples and the Nikes to take pictures to
say I believe in this device this iPhone
to take pictures because it's the best
camera is the one that's with you and
that was radical so that was that was a
different thing and I think the same
thing applies to the folks at home what
is it that you really care about and
what's a lens that you have on the world
that come from in here that is different
I don't think I'm that different than
most people I just had a few really
lucky moments that I took advantage of
and when I was in college one of those
moments hit and I got to co-found a
little business that ended up becoming a
snack bar and a ticket bureau and a
bagel delivery service and a birthday
cake service and a lot of you service
and a travel agency and every week we
started something new we was
semi-related to the college so we got to
use their payroll system and in exchange
we didn't get to keep any of the money
right so it's great cuz I get to explore
all this stuff without the stress of
saying what if it doesn't work right as
I already didn't have anything right and
a couple weeks into it I started to look
at things say you mean I could just go
and start a new thing and no one could
tell me not to yeah and my roommates
didn't understand that and the people on
my hall didn't understand that and my
teacher and as soon as that happened I
stopped trying to get good grades in
school
because no one's ever gonna look at my
grades anyway I started taking as many
courses that they could cuts the same
price to take six instead of four so go
ahead and it just adopted this new
posture which is how do I do things for
the people I'm trying to serve how do I
make interesting things happen because
it's not a race or a contest it's a
journey
yeah you know and I live in New York now
and one of the saddest things was to
watch the tourists go to Olive Garden
why would you go to New York
at the Olive Garden what is that about
right and what it's about is because you
like the regular kind you don't want to
be surprised because you want to do the
safe thing well if that's what you want
then don't be a tourist stay home and I
think the same thing is true about work
like if you want a job where someone's
gonna tell you what to do then go work
for a different fast food place go work
for a place you know where they're just
gonna give you a manual yeah but if you
want a gig where you can put on a show
and be a different kind of human being
because you can yeah there aren't many
companies like Dutch Bros to have
figured out how to let someone do that
there's so many ways to get into these
made out which is exciting it's hard to
navigate so it's important to verify the
right people but um you don't have to
get a visa material take it to a studio
yes I've development money like there's
so many other ways to there's different
funds that help develop material there's
different programs that are once you
know so many writers are if you ask them
and a really super passionate about it
are willing to be partners with you to
get something made and push it to the
next step so you know just thinking
outside the box that there's not just
it's a to be agency it's just a whole
world of changes but I was in like I
remember when I started you know a long
time ago there was just you know the TV
it was this thing and it was only the
three networks and now it's it's
incredible and wealth of opportunity
makes things their online content
everyone use content you know and create
some great stories like big little lives
we got approaches to make it into a film
but it is it's an eight part series so
it's important that there's no rules
anymore it's you know the way people
consume content has totally changed
people don't traditionally go to the
theater as much which is kind of a
bummer at some times
but it's actually really interesting to
go okay instead of thinking that as a
negative like how can we collaborate
with Swedish companies and create
interesting stories and have them you
know find an audience in a different way
so I think it's about I'm looking at
things are going you know angles you
know my brain looks like
of a hole with a hundred percent of like
a a pie chart only like 15 percent has
actual product you know or clothing the
rest of that you know 85 percent it's
like there's marketing there's business
there's build-out this pop-up shops
there's website design there's digital
you know there's culinary there's
furniture you know all these other
things that could serve that same
ingenuity that we brought two t-shirts
you know and that's more what I think is
like I think in the next three four or
five years that these like sort of like
street wear in quotes way of thinking
about cell phones can give us a
different type of cell phone you know
I've been focused on this that like
street wear might be an art movement
that we just don't know we might have
just sort of like short did it the short
end of the stick and called it you know
a state brand and that's what my work is
focused on it's not not necessarily
limiting myself to this way of thinking
in sort of having a dialogue with
fashion and fashion history it's like
how can it relate to how we can make
different products across all realms
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with stained lead that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that I want to
know who do you think thinks outside the
box more Conor McGregor or Kanye West
you saw both of them in this video today
who thinks more outside the box vote it
up leaving the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
can tell you exactly when timely comics
became Marvel actually from timely they
had a lot of other names in the interim
I don't remember all of them but the
last name they had before they became
Marvel was Atlas comics and after we did
the Fantastic Four we did the Hulk
spider-man the x-men and so forth we
suddenly began to realize hey we've got
fans we'd have had fans before we had
never gotten fan mail before but all of
a sudden with the start of our new
superheroes we got real letters I like
this I don't like this you did a great
job on this
so I decided we ought to change the name
of the company get something better than
Atlas and the very first book that
martin goodman had ever published when I
could even before I came to work there
was called Marvel Comics so if he
Marvel's a great word and also there's
so much you could do with it you could
make up slogans and mottos so I decided
I would treat Marvel like a big
advertising campaign and I made up
slogans like make mine Marvel Marvel
marches on welcome to the Marvel Age of
comics you know things like that and I
came up with a lot of catchphrases I
would sign all the things I wrote with
enough said or hang loose or face front
but I noticed that the competition was
starting to use those expressions too so
I figured I've got to get something that
they won't copy and I tried to think of
something a they wouldn't know how to
spell and B they wouldn't know what it
means and that's why I came up with the
word exile C or if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it act like it I
have Tulsa what a wail out of handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I'm
murdered
rock into the stone hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for two hundred fifty
four days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access